you made it
weird itd you made it weird with Pete
hes what's happening weirdos this is
Justin marale someone who is a delight
and I always always always love running
into him I run into him at The Comedy
Store where he crushes on stage but then
also backstage he's always just such a
fun and easy chat so of course I want
wanted to have him on the show and I'm
so glad I did if you don't know him
we're going to play a little bit of his
standup we're going to play a little bit
of his standup comedy right now so you
can get a little bit of a taste so we'll
be right back here's a little bit of Our
Guest today Justin Martell killing it on
stage a lesbian will keep you safe no
matter what and I have the best her name
is
Denise Denise is is an
alpha she is full
Silverback when she gets threatened or
nervous she puffs up and I have to calm
her down with a newborn
kitten I'm like Jane good all for
lesbians she'll puff up get really aggro
and I'm like
Denise
soft soft
oh sorry soft Denise soft soft Denise
all right everybody check out Justin's
podcast it's called just Sayan also he's
headlining across the country go see him
live go see me live Pete homes.com I've
got my Netflix is a Fest show in May on
May the 4th Pete homes.com for tickets
to that that would mean a lot it's a
slightly bigger venue than I'm used to
and I'm really hoping we can sell it out
it would mean a lot and thanks to
everybody who came to Largo this month
we have another one in February it's
almost sold out go to largo-la dcom for
tickets to that and also go to pet
homes.com I'm going to be in Oxnard
going to be in Chicago uh thanks to
everybody who came to Irvine by the way
that was so fun but uh oxen art is next
on Valentine's Day hope you can be there
in the meantime enjoy the wonderful
Justin marale get into it I have a lot
of thoughts already about you having a
dog do you and we're just rolling okay
good it's not like your show with
professional
intros just saying with Justin Martin
it's not like that show you also have to
hold your mic yeah I know like the olden
days just like wer why is it cold it's
very it was freezing in here I turned
the heat on yeah the mic is cold yeah
know it's like a stethoscope I like
hated mics when I arrive so you hate no
I need a hot mic like a heated steering
wheel you ever drive a car with a heated
steering wheel what is just a podcast
snob just like you call this a studio
actually we've gotten that response many
times no many times people have
been I know I say it every time but I
feel like Mark Maron would come in here
and just start screaming but just in
general yeah you know I brought him up
at the store the other night how did
that go it's so
sweet if it goes well you know what I
mean because he came out he was wearing
his little kind of like down by the do
holiday beanie and he I was genuinely
happy to see him and and I brought him
out kindly you know what I mean I feel
like you did so much I did I well that's
what it is it's the old patterns of like
I'm going to win over I'm not saying
he's a grinch but he can be a little
grumpy or a little prickly prickly is a
better word a prickly kagin a prickly
kudin let's say I have quite a few Mark
Marin Burns ready to go yeah that I'll
never use unless it gets twoo int unless
you have to go back because he burns me
a lot yeah oh I know he burns a lot but
I brought him out and I was like he's
one of my favorites and brought him out
I said happy holidays and he went out
and he was like uh Pete Holmes but he
didn't make fun of me and I was like
progress cuz I feel like he doesn't see
me yeah he and I've said this to him and
I think that might have broken us broken
us through where I kind of yelled at him
in the Green Room not yelled but like
raised my voice in a comedy way where I
was like I'm not that 28-year-old squirt
I was there you were
yeah I because I hated that I hated that
hang yeah I was being traumatized left
and right traumatized by Burr
traumatized by mirin not TR Burr wasn't
like attacking me but it was me you Bill
Burr and Marin and lesie Jones I think
the the the five right there the five
Horsemen
marale Holmes bird Marrin Jones I'm the
Lesser horse but yes of course yeah I'm
on my way you're welcome in that re no I
remember that I remember that night yeah
and I tried because I really like Mark I
like him and I want but I'm trying to
get over that people are you a people
pleasy I don't think you are I think I I
think when I first started I was like oh
I got to be friends with everybody and
you know
and now I just don't care because I feel
like I make the effort for sure a for f
yeah is it really A for effort it's e
for effort wow it is this whole
time and the three Rs Reading Writing
arithmetic who wrote this [__]
Cracker Jack the kid from the
crackerjack pop just this a for effort
they mean a I'm giving you the
like person made that and we all just
was like oh he's stupid let's just let
him have it there's a great Jim Gaffigan
joke a for effort how many things are
just someone didn't want to speak up and
he goes there the joke is he goes the
male seahorse has the baby yeah and he
goes shouldn't you just call that the
female seahorse and it was probably like
a scientist making a mistake he's like
and that's the female that's the male
seahorse and he goes it's having a baby
yeah the male has the baby yeah
nobody wanted to correct no one wanted
to so now it's a thing God that that's a
fun drinking game I would think things
that are just things that yeah well mine
is pillage a village that just sounds
like a viking made P Village let's go
pillage that Village pillage the village
excuse me what did you say that's a
mistake yeah let's pillage the village
pillage the village that the [__]
King Blackbeard [__] up yeah and no
one you want to tell him well no one's
going to say anything to Blackbeard tell
Blackbeard with those floppy boots no I
don't want to tell Blackbeard with those
floppy boots you know what I'm talking
about they hang over yes like pirate
boots you could roll them up but they're
rolled down it's casual can you roll
them up though you can't it's soft it's
like a soft it's a flaccid boot yeah
what you call
me you're a classic boot that's that's
what they say for bottom in England put
it in the boot no now it sounds like I'm
trying to say but my first they say to
the
bottom well the trunk is this is stupid
I hate this riff I know I know I know
hey A for effort you
[Laughter]
know why is that a thing that's going to
haunt me all year A for effort yes well
they're giving you an a for the effort
no but it's not no not everyone gets a a
ribbon a certificate no one no
participation f for effort I like f for
effort oh God I don't know I don't know
all right what is a floppy Lea tell me
why your life isn't this Ray and I'm I'm
very happy to see you I'm happy to see
you as well I'm always happy to see you
yes same it's always fun to see you one
of those insta friends insta friends in
friend that's a new app an ally Ally is
kind of sounds like I'm helping you
fight yeah I know I just mean like in
comedy you go there's a friend friendly
yes friendly is better friendly friend I
like that one but you know how like the
Air Force goes it's a friendly no I
don't know that yeah they say that I
think the arms Armed Forces go it's a
friendly okay you should know that in
case you ever want to come out with your
my brother's in the Air
Force you should go is it friendly
that's what you would say to your
brother I'm going to have to call him
and see if like why don't I know that
what if he's a major in the Air Force
he's a major in the Air Force yeah tell
guess who's the favorite well that's
that was my first question yeah does
that work or is it just like who cares
look I'm not saying this is my attitude
but I could see a parent meaning this is
not my attitude saying big deal you
walked into a recruitment office yeah
like you could see it like they got you
or career military doing it for the for
the [__] since he was a kid Captain
America reasons since he was a kid since
he was a child my brother like we're all
playing Super Mario Brothers you know
what other Nintendo games are there he's
playing Kirby Kirby he's playing like
F-15 Blackhawk Down like like Top Gun he
was into it always born a Warrior born a
hero yeah and I remember getting M born
a hero I said Warrior you took it to the
next level straight hero guy over his
shoulders running out of the out of the
Jungle yeah like help and like a child I
remember like like Friday nights you
know your parents go to Blockbuster
we're going to Blockbuster we're going
to R the new movie get a game while we
at it and be like Aaron get the coolest
game out whatever was out he'd come back
with some [__] like yeah platoon
airplane game and I'm
like where the where the like the target
line you know what I'm talking about
like we got to get those whatever that
scale thing is I'm like this sucks I
don't know what are you talking about
whatever like if you're having to like
Target snipe no like when you're in the
air and you have to like Target the the
sucks
this is just a gay guy explaining the
Air
Force you know there's a Target and you
got to launch and missiles
ready allegedly and you're over it over
it but he's like made a career out of it
I'm like older brother he how old is he
is he older no he's younger younger yeah
younger brother he's like 37 30 well no
hold on yeah and in the family he
won yeah yeah I mean I think we've all
won but like I have a sister don't put
my words in your mouth let's not say my
sister has four kids my other brother is
like uh ex Army like did the tours all
that stuff was your dad in the military
yeah oh meanwhile professional
clown do you think your good friend of
mine do you think your dad cries when he
hears the song send in the clowns send
in the clowns he's just like
not just a clown a gay clown I know yeah
yeah gay clown I thought it is what I
mean by I know I was like is he going to
say a gay clown or just a
clown but I don't know what is the
adjective give me the adjective for the
clown it was be your choice and you did
go
dry yeah I'm going to be four
get to it in the new year what was
military dad a lot of assumptions coming
up was that a thing was both of those
things a thing the clown we could talk
about either clown and the gayness or
was it or is that just a stereotype
that's not real in this case like a dad
that doesn't necessarily want a clown or
maybe even a gay clown you know what I
feel like what if you were like you know
what I don't like this conversation like
it's such an early I feel cornered it's
an early morning and I'm like did your
dad how' your dad take that it's fine
actually for Christmas I got a
um a DVD player excuse me yeah $35
that's how much a DVD player is now
that's how much a DVD used to be yeah no
like right no a DVD player remember they
were like 800 bucks for a DVD player why
did you want a DVD player because my dad
converted all of our childhood VHS into
DVDs so my boyfriend got me a DVD player
so all Christmas I was watching like all
these old home movies that I'm just
sitting there like what was the feeling
like crazy this Christmas I went to my
friend er's house and they had a video
it was on VHS though they still have a v
they still had it and we put it in and
there I was and it was look my family
did a great job I'm just saying it was
the age that I was being sort of
challenged yeah I get that what year
what year was what was the challenge it
was junior high it was like around so
what like 10 11 what how old are you
when you're in like sixth grade seven
grade I think like seventh grade 10
11 my's inth grade okay so I was in I
was probably 13 years old I just feel
like it was when comedy really was
coming out of me and it was because you
know some kids skateboarded I know that
sounds stupid but some kids you just
want something to do keep you out of the
house yeah get your mind and that
doesn't mean my house was a war zone I'm
just saying like I I was uncomfortable a
lot I'll say that so what was and
watching it I felt a real oh poor baby
about myself I was like oh it's okay
you'll be okay you'll be okay did you
talk to your younger self I talk to him
all the time yeah tell me your
experience I mean honestly kind of the
same thing
around like right into Middle School
just this little kid and I'm just
looking at him and he's just like
getting in the way and I remember and my
and my dad would just be like just get
the hell out of the picture you know
like my has just like get get get out of
the and I'm like you know oh totally
just a little the China never met we are
the same I had a camera on me and I was
like Kaka you know and he's like Justin
like it's like my my my brother's like
first day on Earth right and my mom's
just holding him and I'm
like he's like get the hell out of the
picture that must be why we're
friendlies cuz that's either your thing
or it's not and you know I have a
5-year-old and I'm I'm it's still to be
determined and I don't have a preference
I'm just watching how she is but then I
also have a nephew who's eight and he's
got the they do he's got a little bit of
I wouldn't say has the overflowing shot
glass that you and I had but he's got
some of it and it's interesting to see
because you can't this is sounds maybe
self-important but it's like you can't
you can't teach that that that sort of
will bind him to me forever in the same
way that you're bound to your young self
I know it's true so was it sad or was it
happy to watch those it was a little sad
cuz like I saw my grandmother and my
grandpa yeah and I was like wow I and I
remember that and they what and they're
doing great they're fantastic you know
they never been better I've never had
death understood like is that are they
passed they're oh yeah yeah yeah that
was like What if I was like no tell me
your grandparents are dead without
telling me your grandparents are dead
like it was a little sad I saw my
grandparents I saw my grandparents doing
well God
gross so were you close with them yeah I
was I was and like my grandpa passed
when I was eight so I'm like watch I'm
seeing the like the year in the date at
the bottom of the screen and then going
oh wow 3 years from now he would be dead
that's how I feel watch so a little
morbid you know is yeah no Bu you're
you're watching these old home videos
and I'm like this time in three years
he'll be gone
yeah like knowing that I don't think
that's moreid I was listening to yach
rock on the way down let's get into
that what song I forget what it was but
uh oh how much how much I
[Music]
feel which by the way if I was following
the plot which I wasn't following it
that closely it's one of those like baby
you're crazy I'm not cheating on you the
70s yeah like where did you yeah that's
that's every song was
that it is totally just a mustache man
there's a little cocaine in it he's like
I don't know where you got it baby I
don't know where you heard these rumors
but they're true but they're not and the
bass player was like just write a a fat
song and she'll forgive you do more
cocaine in the morning skip
coffee I have you seen Daisy Jones in
the six no watch that it's on Amazon
it's a show it's a show on Amazon it's
like pretty much like Fleetwood Mac okay
but it's not but it's 's granddaughter
Riley Riley cof I think is her name know
what I'm talking about she looks just
like her mom it's crazy and um Marie
Lisa Marie Presley's daughter yeah
changed her name oh married someone
named cough I guess so or I don't know
think you hold on to that Presley I yeah
she looks just like him though it's
crazy but it's like really set in the
70s Sunset Boulevard rock and roll
Chateau Mormont good or bad so good
really love it but yeah it's totally
that like 70s wake up all right let's
try the song and a song where you're
saying I'm not cheating but here's the
weird part but they're all like banging
like of course of course and then they
write a song with the person they're
cheating on their they hate each other
on stage and then they're like great job
guys it's so dysfunctional brutal but
the cor okay so the first verse is like
you're you're nuts he's like gas
lighting her basically like I'm not
cheating on you second or third verse
he's like well I've I've moved on this
was years ago I have a wife now it's
going strong wrong but then I I kind of
tuned out but then it comes back to and
that's how much I feel about you and I'm
like so you're going to cheat on your
wife with her right so you are a cheater
that's the whole show that's the whole
show believe people when they tell you
who they are or when they're singing who
they aren't but what I love about that
is like before there was internet or
like text messaging all they had was a
look all they had to do was like look
across the room and be like buddy it was
all how did you look at me yeah that was
all that's why there were so many pans
being saw you across the room looked
across the floor I I felt like you
touched your hand a little too long now
it's just like blow on a screen get it
real clean get their passcode and then
just read them sexting yeah then you're
like pretty sure this is getting F send
dong send dong right at the top just oh
a dong you're seeing song Wait tell me I
was saying you're looking at your
partner's phone you're saying
I'm just saying that's how it is now
like it's just they just get not even
just there's just Jal yeah here it is
here they are can I here's my junk as a
not dickpic sending person really really
yeah as a not dick sending person just
how many people are just going on Google
and finding a dick is that a big thing
one that question keeps me up at night
really I am fascinated by that I want to
know how many of them are
real who cuz you could find one that
looks like yours yeah you know what I
mean you don't want to advertise on the
billboard and then at the premiere right
right right right it's I don't want it
to be like the red carpet like step and
repeat it's just you want to be able to
live up to it yeah but I could I feel
like I could very in fact sometimes when
I I don't uh watch a lot of porn but
when I do I tend to find I'm looking for
a ding-dong that looks like my own
interesting is that not a preference for
you no really I don't think no really
let me ask you this Justin I don't think
you're thinking about it enough okay now
that I but now you're watching it now
let's just say let's just go to the
extreme it's a tiny tiny W wiener you're
not going to watch that fair yeah no but
there there actually was one that I was
like that looks like mine yeah yeah and
I was
like yeah there I am good for me yeah
but I yes I feel like guys now who are
looking online and looking for fake
dicks they're dick lighting their women
in instead of gaslighting Dick lighting
and then they're ass lighting you back
yeah but it kind of doesn't really
matter it's just like we're sending nude
pictures can't that be enough why does
it have to be me gu I just don't know
when that all became a thing I'm
not I don't think that's like when did
that become like the hello you know what
I mean you can do that now with anybody
like go on Instagram go into their
little link
tree oh they have an only fans they've
got a what's go their Twitter and then
Twitter people just send dpic into their
Twitter just nudes just nudes just naked
first move first move everyone's just
naked now in
Twitter well that's clear rather than
subscribing be a cheap [__] like
myself and go to Twitter and be like
there it is all right I'm over
it no patience for nudes I don't but
aren't in this scenario aren't you
sending the nudes you're I don't send
nudes no no you know what's funny is I
think I'm wearing a pair I am I'm
wearing a pair of underwear that says
send
nudes with noodles yeah with noodles
that's great and how how bad does that
hurt you're like I think I've lost
weight so I have extra good I'm like you
know when you get that stomach surgery
and you make a wallet oh yeah no an old
pirate boot the flap you make an old
pirate boot I'm not fat shaming I'm just
saying their skin or it could just be a
major weight loss there's a lot of
people that talk about major weight loss
and it's like I got to do something with
this skin you make a drum
that I know loose skin so you just got a
dog seems like an edit but it's not was
a real life like we were in a topic that
wasn't great and then all of a sudden I
go so you got a dog and the audio kind
of changed that wasn't an edit the clip
doesn't even it's an old VHS tape
yeah like [__] Cloverfield so your
your grandparents are dead yes oh it
tracks a little bit I got a dog I got a
dog you see the Monster Drop in the
Ocean yeah oh yes uh I liked Cloverfield
I did too and I just started watching
the Godzilla I watched all the shows
over the break I Haven seen they it up
so much that a giant monster is the most
interesting thing in the world yeah but
like nine out of 10 of those movies are
just [__] snoozes oh yeah horrible
well the the how do they blow it I don't
know it's like King Kong too it's like
it should be incredible mhm and it's
like why am I the most bored I've ever
been uh Jordan Voit Roberts did a good
King Kong movie I like that one what was
that one it doesn't Skull Rock or Skull
Island is that the one I think so skull
yeah because he I think he did a good
job showing the scale but most of the
time now it's like once you zoom out and
he's just walking with a thing if
there's no reference point right it just
looks like a [__] [__] well and I
want to see the Monster yeah like
get I hate movies where you're like it's
coming just come on that's how I feel
about New Year's they're like Midnight's
coming the whole night everyone's
postponing their most fun till the
countdown yeah and I'm like and then you
do it and you realize you're the same
[__] you were yeah when you were
waiting for it same I I we watched New
York I was like there it is yeah they
did it yeah and then is there anything
that they're trying manufacture more
meaning than New Year's Eve those poor
hosts going like talking to John Mayer
it's already New Year what can you tell
us about the new year I did love John
Mayer at the cat CFE we enjoyed it but
those questions you know what it is it's
I did love that uh Andy Cohen got drunk
and said passed around like a party
bottom on CNN he said that oh yeah
passed around passed around like a party
bottom a party bottom yeah and that is
presumably just the design at party
bottom yeah designated ass for the party
some people you know pass out chips it's
a chip and dip it's a different kind of
chip and dip yeah I was like party
bottom Jesus God Is this where we're at
it is I guess yeah we're a post meaning
Society I heard they got in trouble for
boozing it up and then last year they
didn't booze it up and then this year
only back what is the non- Anderson one
named Andy con the non Anderson what's
the non Anderson Andy Cohen yeah Andy
yeah yeah no my wife was like was but
they only had a shot like every hour oh
they were booing they were boozing yeah
oh okay I think Andy might have had a
little bit before yeah but like Anderson
was actually okay trying to keep it
together yeah it it just feels like
daytime radio it's there what if you're
John Mayor and someone says it's already
2024 in Japan what's it like like what
what do you even say to that that's why
he was in a cat cafe he was like who
cares and I think that's was kind of
amazing he was like yeah I I enjoyed
that yeah I don't those those New Year's
e Eve events show me just how desperate
and sweaty and stupid show business
really is when it's unprepared and it
just lights and they're like let's go
into the crowd and they're like so how
long you been in the waiting for I've
been [__] my pants since 8 in the
morning good for you Beverly but then I
talked to Val about it I was waiting for
my show to start Val was just watching
it having a cocktail with her friends
and she loved it yeah so really I'm
jealous that people can just kind of
like let loose and enjoy and I'm out
working no where were you Tempe don't
say Tempe oh yeah they get mad they get
mad Tempe you were in Tempe on New Years
Tempe did you do the midnight I did even
though I made fun of New Year's pretty
much exactly what I just said to you I
was ripping into how dumb New Year's is
and then at the end of I head I was like
I'll be back out to do the countdown
with oh gross and we did it I was the
pass around power bottom yeah you were I
was the chip and dip I was like so you
came out and you were just like guys the
moment we've all been waiting for and
God love them they were they were into
it cuz I did I did check myself
presumably after I wrecked myself cuz I
was like who am I to pooo yuck someone
else's yum if you like New Year's it's
fine are you into it no yeah I like the
I like the thought of like dressing up
and going somewhere and but then it's
like $800 to like sit at a table and
then it's like we're going to give you
like shrimp and like champagne at
midnight and you're like okay bad
champagne at midnight it's gou I mean I
was at my friend's house and we just
like watched New Year's we just went
outside and watched all the fireworks
and went to bed yeah was it we had some
karaoke in the living room which is why
my voice is like this yeah how do how do
you feel today I'm kind of out of sorts
I'm out of sorts I don't know what's
happening yeah what is it Katie are you
out of sorts what is it what is it I
know this is how we should have started
what is it what is it what is it for
real I was driving down there's this
great n Nate baratti joke he has about
eating a stack of pancakes in the rest
of the day he's like sleepy and he's
like but he can never put it together
that it was the pancakes he's just
walking around and he goes I just can't
get it going and Val and I say I just
can't get going and this is one of those
days where I'm like I just can't get it
going it's weird that we're back yeah
here we are we have to catch up we have
to catch up we have to catch up and
we're like okay the holidays are over
like I even today was like we're taking
the tree down I was just going to the I
was just going to say I took lights off
the house yesterday cuz they were
falling down yeah and the tree is about
to go the tree is as
brittle as [__] It's like got rig
mortise yeah you touch it and you can
hear death just you said it curb me put
me to the curb
please just I shouldn't be just take me
out of the house put it on the CB
recycle me already I'll make a nice book
for a child in Florida that they'll ban
please he's got
dreams but winter is the time of death
Halloween should be in the winter it it
is sort of it's like the beginning of
the winter some states yeah but it's
like Halloween is when you're dying but
winter is when you're
dead now we're just dead and you know
this spring is when life spring is
sprung you're coming back to life pill
The Village spring spring is sprung and
we're in this nebulous time where like
at least we had Christmas yeah lights
even if you don't celebrate you have
Holiday Lights you know what I'm saying
like you go to the Grove Jewish Muslim
atheist Christian everyone enjoys the
sprinkle dinkle yeah we don't have snow
we're gonna put soap everyone we're
gonna have soap fall from the sky look
up open your eyes and get soap in your
eyes get lie poisoning right to the
retina but it just makes you cheery and
then something about New Year rolls
around and you go all right all the help
is gone yeah now you're just an ice
fisherman make it quick make it quick
and we live in sunny sunny ass
California and it's still kind of like
like I about on stage I go like we
shouldn't be here shouldn't we be like
in a log cabin yes listening to our Papa
listening to No feratu you know like
that's not no Fatu no
radamus like I actually wait nose for
nose Fatu is a vampire is the vampire
but how do you blend nose Fatu and no no
far you can't blend them
no forgot to it's the same you should be
listening to prophecy prophecy a man
looking in a black mirror there's
nothing I hate more than like the first
week after New Year's going back to the
comedy clubs and being
like
hey it's the feeling of waking up 6
hours too early that's what January is
January is the worst and if you're
listening and you feel this way and if
it's your birthday this month happy
birthday but January sucks there's
nothing I can't handle it January Tundra
I can't handle December 26 is a bummer
my wife and I still put on Christmas
music it's so desperate it's like you
broke up but you're still kind of your
picture is still your wallpaper there's
nothing more lame than like Santa's gone
let let him let him go let him go let
him go girl stop it move on please do
not text him he's at the South Pole girl
he's on vacation he does not want to
hear from you stop blowing up Chris
Kringle it's the worst stop sliding into
his DMS after Christmas he's tired he
doesn't care about you and he has floppy
pirate boots absolutely he does this
whole thing is folding in on
itself yeah didn't you do
methamphetamine
once I'm not just bringing it up as
randomly as it seems I'm thinking what
does Santa do when he's off and I'm like
this is when he goes and does a little
the other kind he's in Tiana he's at a
donkey show he's like I need to get the
reindeer like you know oh is he watching
or is he getting plowed by the
donkey how much time do we have we
have we don't have that much
time I didn't see correctly that you
smoked
meth did you smoke math like years ago
one time okay that's good it was in 2002
I always think about the same I think
2002 or 2003 yeah just one time that was
it no no nobody thinks look at you
you're robust you're robust the car not
five minutes ago it does I I feel bad
for uh obviously all addiction but
especially meth people because you know
you look like you there's a look isn't
it weird everybody gets a look if you do
a lot of meth I suppose if you do a lot
of coke it's not the same maybe you get
skinny or there's not a look necessarily
no well on cocaine you think if you do a
lot yeah well I mean it does stuff to
your teeth it does stuff to your skin in
a different way it is it is it's I
really was just trying to say you
clearly are robust you look like you've
got some sun you're doing great so no
one here thinks you're on meth read the
comments below everyone no Martin Dale
on meth no no no that was I mean it was
that was one first of all I didn't know
what it was methamphetamine yeah had no
idea someone just gave you a little
someone gave me a thing and they were
like smoke this and I was like okay
where like an idiot huh where were you I
was in
Dallas I was at church I was I was at
the mall with Santa and um you know no
it was in Dallas and this guy was like
here and I'm like okay granted it was in
a light bulb so that was a little
sketchy you mean it was like one of
those glass things no it was a light
bulb excuse me yeah he took the end off
the light bulb and it was just a little
piece of like paper in the light bulb
and he was like we light this up and we
smoke it and I was like what is this he
was like it's called ice and I was like
ooh drama cold it also just sounds like
a cologne yeah right sounds or a gum try
it it's ice it's ice meth would do meth
needs a rebranding yeah it you want to
try Arctic freeze yeah give it like a
Gatorade like this is um cucumber Pita
you know this is ice Tundra ooh yeah I
got you in the door uh-huh so it's like
sold I always think about the scene in
Breaking bed where Jesse Jesse Yeah
gives the the cashier meth in exchange
for gas and she's never done it and he's
like he says it's cold that's what he
said he goes it's really clean and cold
what what was it like what was meth like
yeah well the one time I did it it wasth
last time I stop saying you've done it
once you love it
no I remember just getting so chatty
yeah like we went out and I was at the
bar and the Bender was looking at me and
I was just like you ever think about
like I was just like 900 miles an hour
yeah and C in that way I supp kind of
sort of yeah and then going home not
being tired and rearranging my entire
living space like moving chest of dra
yeah like moving my TV moving my bed we
hired somebody we needed a couch put
together and we put it together pretty
quick we were like pretty sure this was
years ago we're like I think this dude's
on meth cuz he was meth movers that
should be a
thing you got to get out of somewhere
quick hire meth movers steroids is to
professional sports meth is to the
moving to the moving company yeah but my
roommate came outside and he was like
what the [__] are you doing it's like 4
in the morning and I was like just
wanted to change it up a bit so like a
fervor yeah like a energ so it's a
stimulant very it's it's something but
then when I finally went to bed I think
it was like 6 or 7 in the morning I woke
up at like 3:00 or 4: in the afternoon
the next day and let me tell you
like it was the worst feeling I oh it
was just it burnt up all your dopamine
or something oh my well that's how it
becomes so addictive cuz you got to get
it back you got to get it back you got
to win it back so like right when you do
it the one time you do it is you're
already hooked really cuz it's already
in your system so how did you go around
that sweat it out boo you did it oh yeah
I was like never again again no
disrespect to people that can't do that
but it's remarkable and that's admirable
that you did it so you had a conscious
moment where you're were like that was
something I should not have done and
there was a moment of selflove where you
were like this is a cross roads yeah and
I'm going to hurt now let's not do this
installment plan let's do the withdrawal
now and never do it again yeah good for
you and I was just like nope never never
never never never it was just you just
sweat I yeah I just remember how I felt
yeah just like I mean you feel like the
worst hangover ever plus you're just
your body just
feels dead cuz you're just like uh yeah
and I just remember the sweats and the
head and the pulsating and just like all
of it just like uh yeah and I was like
I've never never do that again so going
back to your parents then so I got a dog
yeah no no not even the dog cuz there's
a re we'll get to the
dog I love
this this episode is brought To Us by
our friends at ritual for years guys I
had gaps in my diet nutrient gaps
whenever I went to the doctor for my
checkup every year they told me all the
things I was deficient in thank God I
found ritual the simple traceable Gap
filling once a day multivitamin which is
better than multivitamins I've tried in
the past for so many reasons first of
all I fast so the fact that ritual is
gentle on an empty stomach is huge and
the reason for this is that it doesn't
start breaking down until it's in your
low intestine which is also where
nutrients can actually be absorbed so
it's gentle on your stomach but it also
gets into your system so if you're like
me and you've taken in the past and you
get the feeling that you're just peeing
it out and your pee is bright yellow
like Predator blood and you're like this
is a waste ritual has got you covered
they figured it out and Men guys you
need this more than ever you want ritual
on your team to fill those gaps with 10
key nutrients according to the CDC fewer
men than women meet the daily minimum
for fruit and vegetable consumption and
are more likely to overvalue exercise
and undervalue nutrition so get ritual
into your life I've been taking it for
years every morning I take a for men
gets me ready to start my day feeling
confident that my body has all that it
needs and I take their symbiotic Plus
for my gut health which of course your
gut is like a second brain you got to
feed it it's huge ritual is vegan
gluten-free non- GMO and major allergen
free so get essential for men quality
multivitamin from a company you can
actually trust get 20% off your first
month for a limited time at ritual.com
weird start ritual or add essential for
men to your subscription today that's
ritual.com for 20/ weird ritual.com
weird for 20% off this episode is also
brought To Us by our friends at next Evo
my favorite CBD the new year is a
perfect time to move on from things that
just aren't working in your life with
next Evo natural CBD products oilbased
CBD can be one of them you know I love
CBD to relax to recover to deal with
stress or to help my sleep and CBD is a
plant-based Game Changer in my life but
not all CBDs are created equal oil B CBD
doesn't mix well with our water-based
bodies so you absorb as low as 6% of the
CBD on the label 6% next Evo Naturals
has figured this out they developed a
clinically tested water soluble form of
CBD and their gummies and capsules are
proven to work faster and absorb four
times better than oilbased products
their stress gummies are a lifechanger
for me I have them in my travel bag
they're in my cupboard they help me
manage and cope with stress quickly and
effectively so wonderful to have
something plant-based that is good for
you helping you manage stress that is
natural and now try their strongest
gummy ever the new Extra Strength daily
Wellness CBD gummies which customers and
I personally love or try the all-time
bestsellers their stress gummies which I
love or dissolvable powders which I've
just started adding to my smoothie in
the morning especially after a work out
to aid in recovery so leave oil behind
and start the new year with a more
effective and fast acting CBD from new
next Evo Naturals from next Evo Naturals
get 25% off any order or up to 60% off
as a new subscriber by using Code weird
at next evo.com that's 25% off your
order or up to 60% off a new
subscription at neext evo.com with promo
code weird back to
Justin I feel us coming this is a great
episode but I'm you're bringing life
into me and I really appreciate it but
to go to your parents it seems like not
that it would be their fault if you did
just start smoking meth but like you it
seems like you have a good
foundation yeah good was your childhood
good yeah cuz that not to be a
stereotype there are people with great
foundations that that are addicts in
their DNA and it's a disease and all of
that with full respect but if you're in
the if you have the agency to make a
choice I do think you lean on like was
were you given a foundation and and so
your parents were there for you they
were there yeah um yeah they kind of
just let me I knew right from wrong for
the most part and I just feel like
I I don't know I felt like I dealt with
peer pressure differently when I was a
kid what do you mean I don't know I just
felt like I always wanted to fit in and
I always wanted to
be um not cool but I just I Never Had A
specific group of friends I was kind of
like a social butterfly like I had
different groups of friends the jocks
the Nerds the B kids like yeah we're
we're friendlies so like if someone was
like Justin do this I'd be like all
right I'll do it you know or if like oh
I don't want to do that give it to
Justin like oh wait okay so now we we've
diverged meaning if there was something
wild to do you would do it yeah so
that's what you mean like you were kind
of strange when it came to peer pressure
yeah and I also didn't
really I wasn't
around drugs like I knew what weed was
and I knew what like alcohol was but I
wasn't like a big like cocaine or you
know meth or anything like that pills
what were the wild things though the
wild things what did they want you to
do who the the friends that are like get
Justin to do it well I mean it wasn't it
wasn't never really that until like I
got out of my hometown then it was like
oh now you're the little fish in the big
pond you know what I mean okay but what
were they what when you were the social
butterfly with all the different groups
what were you known for for like I would
you know I would drink and uh
uh I mean I would I would smoke pop but
nothing nothing crazy I wasn't like one
of those kids who showed up to class
yeah like [__] up you know what I mean
right um looking back I it never
occurred to me when I was in high school
but I'm like oh they were drunk yeah I
had friends who were like on um God what
what did they do I had friends who did
Coke I had friends who but I I never did
that in in school I was just kind of
like M no still a little dangerous to me
but then getting out of it and being
like come on don't you want this and
like everyone's looking at you you're
like okay and where are we in the
country where were raised in Texas okay
so where you did math MH yeah well it's
crazy because right above Dallas there
was a town called Plano and they had
like a huge like heroin problem like
back in the early yeah where kids were
just like at parties House part and
doing heroin and dying yeah so it's just
crazy that I was just like wow why did I
not you dodged that yeah and now it's
just so scary like I don't want to touch
anything anymore cuz it's all I'll kill
you no I know it's we've we've lost
people in the past couple years because
of that I've never heard a convincing
reason why drug dealers are putting
fentanyl in things that because it's not
free no I've heard that they do it
to a a rival's drug Supply to get them
in trouble but I was like that seems
very brutal and how did you even do it
it's so s it's like and why I don't know
it it does seem incredibly brutal I know
I mean we've lost Betty White we've lost
um Betty was
a that's a new rumor fentel yeah you
didn't hear about that no yeah that's a
that's a fresh that was just her street
fake rumor that's a fake rumor nobody
quote that that is pretends yeah that's
insane so okay I don't want to presume
but we going back to the military dad I
I love
all meaning I don't mean to be obvious
and talk about coming out but I one of
the reasons I'm drawn to it is because
every person gay straight or otherwise
has to figure out who they are and and
come to terms with it and present it and
negotiate with their reality and and be
born a new so that's why I'm drawn to
those stories I I don't mean to assume
it was one for you maybe it was very
simple but I'm getting like military dad
military
brother uh and then Texas was it as
interesting as that kind of sounds like
it might
be um oh like me coming out yeah um like
when when did you start putting your own
story together I mean I I always kind of
knew but it wasn't talked about and when
it was talked about it was evil it was
dangerous it
was against God so you always see these
like oh you were raised religious oh
yeah I mean Texas you know for sure so I
mean there were those nights where it
was like you know you always see them in
these like new LGBT movies that are
coming out stuff where the kids in bed
like Don't Make Me Gay Don't Make Me Gay
like praying so there were a couple of
those and then just kind of like wait
you did that you mean or oh yeah really
oh for sure what a nightmare yeah so
how I'm like you know that's what we
did I remember being pre-sexual but
being so sort of conditioned like by you
know family members being like you got a
little girlfriend and all that sort of
stuff well that I mean that was the same
yeah of course but meaning I can't tell
you when I realized I was really
straight what I'm saying that's hard for
me to pinpoint but somewhere around
Junior High I'm
assuming like
that yeah I knew yeah I knew things were
were uh different about me definitely I
want to say like fifth grade sixth grade
going into that where it was
like you know you're looking you know
you're looking at all the girls and
you're like wait I'm supposed to like be
into them and then you're looking over
at your like guy friends and you're
like okay so I would always date like
the
frps yeah don't say I would always take
the FR like the girls that like you know
don't say
always take the FRS so I'd be like cute
handsome Justin with Shannon over here
you know and she's
like you know with blunt bangs and a bob
and a
mustache and I'd be like I love
her so much she got me a teddy bear from
the um fud Ruckers
yeah you're looking for all these like
circumstantial things to like them about
it was safe it was like yeah it wasn't
going to go anywhere it wasn't going to
go anywhere you know as a straight but
religious person I would also want to
date the people that I didn't want to
date someone fast or that's such an old
phrase but you know what I mean I didn't
want to I wasn't actually looking to
have sex in fact I remember being like
why go on a date nothing's going to
happen yeah my parents are dropping me
off and then picking me up that's what I
mean gross you watch say by the Bell and
he's like I'll pick you up at 6 I'm like
how for what for what and how and where
are you going to go and how do you to go
sit at a movie and and be
quiet God it was the worst it is the
worst and I remember like getting into
high school things started to like
change for me because I really got into
into theater and that was kind of
my sport cuz I felt like um cuz in Texas
we had like
competitive like theater was called UIL
it was like all it was the Arts it was
like you know speech debate theater and
all that kind of stuff so it was like
really competitive competitive theater
how compete with theater with with plays
like you would have you have like 40 to
45 minutes to like it was called one act
I just watched amadas La yesterday and
they would do that in in Mozart's time
yeah where they'd have two act plays in
one night and they'd vote on the winner
so I know this this that it was like
um uh you had a very minimal set and you
had to like decorate the set every
school had the same set and we had to
like configure it and make it look like
the the wait you mean you have the same
blocks you have the same blocks like
Minecraft yeah kind of yeah and it's
like do something with this do something
with this it was really cool and you had
45 minutes you could be disqualified if
you like crossed the line early if you
went over you could be disqualified like
and there was like best even if the play
ended before 45 minutes if the play
ended after after 45 minutes it would be
a shy you could be a little shy yeah you
just had to make it through and like
yeah it was like real technical I mean
it was like a marathon like go go go go
go it was it was so much fun 24hour film
festival it was great and like you'd go
to state you get a trophy J padle and I
competed against each other from uh
Supernatural oh no way yeah so he's a
Texas guy and I remember he and I were
like one year we were like son of a
[__] I'm going to be actor this year
and then he won and I was like okay well
let's see how that works works out for
you and were you The
Shining Star were you good at it yeah
yeah yeah you found your thing that was
my thing yeah and so like I dated like a
lot
of like girls like hot girls and then
because you were hot [__] in the H [__]
yeah and then you get and then you leave
and then you're just kind of like all
right now I guess I can be myself I
don't want to make I'm just asking you
as a person not to be the spokesperson
but why I was drawn to theater straight
guy gay people drawn to theater is it
just it's it's got to be less about
sexuality there had to be gay people
that aren't drawn to theater but
something about like what is the draw
that's what I'm saying for you what was
it like oh I think it was just like
escapism yeah it was imagination it was
storytelling but don't you think I guess
what I'm saying to draw the line there
there's something about
repression of all types and I've made
this joke I've probably made this joke a
billion times but I'm like as a
fundamentalist I felt like I had to out
as straight like I had to come to terms
with the fact that I was deeply horny
and I had to repress that and then
repress everything repress ugly feelings
anger greed rage lust all that stuff so
then you see the theater and comedy and
improv and all these things and you're
like this is a place where you can like
like mask work you can go up and be a
little devil and be a little different
and everyone's like oh he's just
entertaining you know what I mean I
could be that yeah I could could be a
guy impersonating a woman right I could
be a guy impersonating you know someone
with feminine characteristics and to
have the license do that and they're
like oh yeah he's just uh he's so funny
he's just you know I would I just
watched The Little Richard documentary
did you see that no but I mean girl girl
for real but that was in like the 50s so
it's just such an again I'm not making
you the gay Authority I'm just talking
to you Justin it's very interesting that
this history our country has been so
tight mhm you know puritanical Roots all
this stuff 1950 yeah racism is at
McCarthy era communist paranoia did you
watch fellow Travelers no it's it's
probably a little too much for me yeah
but it's the same thing it's like it's
well I mean I don't know it's it's it's
Jonathan Bailey and Matt Bower and they
play these um guys who work in DC during
the m trials where it's like communism
and homosexuality is a sin and the raids
and you're getting into like milk and
his Harvey milk's assassination you're
getting into the AIDS epidemic and
you're just like holy [__] this is how
it was like two guys on the street just
like we don't want to be seen together
it's like they're two gay men yeah but
one of them's married one of them is
yeah uh from Catholic faith and but then
look at Little Richard right yeah it's
not a new thing uh we have a million
examples now but wanting to see a gender
gender bending can you say that that's
not like an offensive thing no but like
exploring the vages of gender it's
offensive I just got a I got a tweet
that it is yeah you have access to an
app that I don't
have just a red alarm goes off ohh oh
Pete Holmes has cancelled # New Year
2024 okay well but gender fun yeah
goodbye I look up and you're just gone
the mic is ice cold but you know playing
with the the definitions of gender goes
back to Little Richard and goes back to
like it goes way way before that R like
yeah but then what's more fascina Little
Richard isn't that fascinating as much
as the
embracing by straight white squares
nerds that
[__] love it to the point where
you're like oh they need it I'm going to
make a weird jump here but in the way
that the most Square person in the world
just picture the most Meek Quiet Woman
living in Vermont and she doesn't cuss
and she doesn't chew gum cuz it's crass
or whatever oh yeah goes to bed at night
and has a dream that a flying dildo
spaceship is chasing her on a planet in
the ground is tapi meaning we need
expression we need art and we need that
art to be loud and bright and absurd
even I'm not saying Little Richard is
absurd but we want to be like craving it
like sunlight so you when I'm watching
all these like there a lot of them are
racist and all of them I'm going to say
all of them are homophobic except the
ones that are maybe you know closeted
but you're going to see Little Richard
and we all look the other way on it you
know what I mean like a culture Elton
John Liberace but what is this again I'm
not looking to you to figure it out I'm
just saying like well I'll tell you what
it is fascinating and what is the new
one who's the hot guy you know who I'm
talking about he's always shirtless I'm
going to look so stupid he's a huge pop
who's the biggest male pop star right
now oh uh male pop star oh God don't
quiz me cuz I'll I mean Harry Styles
Harry Styles is is another kind of sim I
I I haven't seen five seconds of very
Styles but some in the Little Richard
documentary they they Prince is another
one likey George we [__] I'm going to
say it we need it and we've always
needed it and just like how a
Thanksgiving dinner uh you know the
family isn't acknowledging someone is
gay someone is trans someone is whatever
it is an atheist it doesn't matter but
someone's an other and we all ignore it
and that's so painful but we even do
that culturally the homophobic racist
who loves Little Richard like you you
have cognitive dissonance
is part is like the most American thing
in the world what I think yeah and I
think that's the sad part about
everything is
like I feel like you're supposed to
question all that stuff I want I and I
feel like that's what's so great about
life is that it takes you out of your
comfort zone you know you're you we're
talking about the lady in Connecticut
who's dreaming of dildos and like and
can't help it and can't help it and that
would break my heart if she woke up and
was like there's something wrong with me
I'm broken yeah I need to go to therapy
or go to a priest or like no you just
you just had a dream about something you
know it's like explore that like it
doesn't make you bad it doesn't make you
it's totally normal but there's not
enough people saying that it's normal
that's where the other hot theory that
I'd love to get your take on is how much
is like homophobia transphobia even just
like sexually Free People of all types
and there's hate towards that and I'm
like how much of that is jealousy how
much of it is girl girl right I think so
many things go down to why can't I
Shimmer why can't I shine you see Elton
John literally in a sequin thing and you
know the guys in my dad's Barber Shop
not necessarily my dad but would be like
look at this [__] whatever and I'm
like don't you want to
twinkle I want to know why not me I want
to know why where's my Cod piece yeah
where is your pirate boot Cod piece
where's your renfair Cod piece but
here's I'm going to say something yes
tell
me why does Dave Chappelle talk about
trans people so much tell
me I yep I I I did not enjoy I just put
it on yesterday why why why tell me tell
me why Bo let's go tell me
why I don't know I don't know and it it
blows do you think it's doth protest a
little too much doth protest why are you
so fascinated by a demographic of people
that is just uh statistically is a very
small group I mean it's one it could be
it could be bigger we don't know but
like we're saying it's not a lot of
people but there's an obsession so
obsessed with it if he were a preacher
mhm we would immediately say this person
you you know the guy that's like gay
people are the worst is always caught
having an the youth pastor in Oklahoma
oh there it is like that's an
interesting idea it blows my mind and
I'm not saying anything it just I look
at it as is it funny that because he's
Chappelle we have to be like like I
don't okay go ahead I don't care
like great you smoke on stage it's 1987
again you know like I don't care I don't
care tell me
everything I don't live in fear of these
people I'm not saying anything meaning
you're going like something else is
going on else going on and I don't
understand it and I feel like it's just
like fueling this fire of like machismo
and anger and [__] that we all are
trying to move on from but it's just
still something there that needs to be
talked about yeah and then somebody
pulls out a phone and he cancels the
show really yeah that happened no over
the weekend yeah I'm just saying wait
over the tell me what tell me what your
reference was he was performing on stage
and he saw some guy with a phone and he
just walked off the stage and didn't go
back on really yeah because it would
leak
sure I'm like I don't know I don't I
mean it just it just breaks my heart
because it's
like when you're that infatuated with
something and you're like baiting it and
making it negative and these people are
just trying to live their lives yeah and
also I mean we're we're I'm not breaking
any new ground here but these are people
that are at risk yeah for self harm
always yeah that need more help yeah I
do I do see I'm I'm watching somebody
that is a Master Chef has the potential
to cook a really interesting dinner kind
of serve up some some White Castle like
like that's how it feels to me and and
you do kind of go like why yeah like
really why and you're kind of saying I
just don't get it I'm
like
it's it's just like I feel
like if you just embraced people with
differences you're just expanding your
audience and your reach right you know
it's
like I could not imagine going up on
stage
and pigeon ho holding like a demographic
of people yeah and just running with
that and having people look at me and go
well that's okay right he can do that
like what right oh well it's comedy it's
comedy it's comedy okay okay but when
does it stop being funny right well I'll
give you Anam a Counterpoint right I
used to get very up in arms where I was
like if you're doing jokes at a comedy
club about drunk driving to a bunch of
people who are drinking and a large
number of them are considering driving
home drunk and and this was a very
common closer i' I've made this point
before forgive me me but it's like they
do this joke I I would watch it more
than one comic it's it's like it's like
a freebie joke a lot of Road guys do
yeah it's like remember if you're
thinking about driving home drunk they
can't catch us all something like that
yeah yeah yeah and I would be sitting
there going
like buddy you ever get a little caught
up in how sliding do reality is how
vulnerable we are to everything this
conversation will change your life I
don't mean I'm going to blow your mind
and change everything I just mean if I
decide to be kind to you or unkind to
you the ripples of that and I know this
is so boring it sounds like we're stoned
but it's actually the most interesting
thing in the world we are affecting each
other yeah we are here to either take
care of each other or hurt each other
and words can be murder and words can
lead to murder words can lead to death
and I see jokes that are like
unconsciously or you know meaning
indirectly supporting domestic abuse in
indirectly supporting drunk d driving so
that example I'm like this isn't a joke
if you're drunk in an alpha position a
loud lit onstage glorified person tells
you they can't catch us
all that I'm going to I'm going to say I
don't have the evidence but I'm like I
remember what it would be like to be
drunk and I remember what it would be
like to listen take that as advice and
then maybe be more like I'm going to say
for me definitely be more likely to do
something I wouldn't have done God I
can't get us all it's almost like you're
like extending the show right he's
right they're not going to catch me but
that brick wall will in the same way you
see the correlation I'm making is like
if you're saying things to an atrisk
Community that's already you know
hurting yeah that does have an impact of
course it does it's very interesting to
me too because it's like I'm not saying
that I'm like some sensitive [__]
whatever you want to call me it's like I
know I go up we bring bring each other
up all this stuff I'm still getting
brought up to like you know keep it
going for Justin I don't know about you
guys but I think he's
gay is that I love collecting this data
and getting it out there the like please
stop these kind of jokes data thank you
for sharing that I I wouldn't say that
no no no no but I mean it's like that
but that's not me going how dare you no
I'm like right they know what are you
doing right right right right cool but
also are you trying to like be little me
for having a good set and of course well
what I'm saying is of course it's like
it's like say if it was what I'm saying
is of
course it's like he might have done
better than I did it's like say if Eliza
went up or something and I'm not
comparing myself to Eliza at all but
like say of Eliza did go up and then
someone went up after Eliza and they're
like keep it going for that woman
everyone I don't know about you but I
think she has a vagina yeah she's got a
vagina like it's it's just it's just
very like come on on right right well
that kind of ties into the Chappel nness
meaning when I see it I see someone
who's uh wound or crossed to bear or
whatever the the I look for in myself
the lines that like you cross this line
and I hate that I even have them yeah
but I'll give you examples like I can't
feel ignored by Val like if Val is
ignoring me and I'm feeling vulnerable
I'll get really I'll turn into a little
baby like I'll start like looking for a
ition and I really had to check that I
was like what am I doing in the same way
I I sometimes get really worked up going
like I I sometimes get the feeling I'd
be more I I'd draw sell more tickets if
I just embraced it and became a clean
comedian then I was like I have this
very hot ember in me that goes no I was
raised religious I spent so much of my
life suppressing how I really feel and
doing that like isn't I was being an
observational comedian for the first 25
years of my life I don't just mean on
stage I was just living a life like hey
is a funny name for straw hey who named
it that and like inside I was confused
and scared and angry all of the feelings
so I have a chip on my shoulder where I
go like I am doing you know I don't want
to flatter myself but when I think of
myself as an artist it's because I go if
I feel it strongly I want to talk about
it and that's a non-negotiable for me
even if it means it I'd be doing better
commercially if I would just do hey
jokes or whatever it might be so that's
my chip what I when I watch Chappelle I
try I'm trying to have compassion for
everybody including him and I'm going
like he seems to have a a a chip that
says no one can tell me not to do
something it's almost like a kink I
don't mean it's sexual but it's like
it's irrational and there's an
overcorrection of if we say don't do
jokes about that he really like you can
see him on a hill with a flag and like a
a purpose to be like you know he gave
that talk at his school and he was like
that's the point it's like no one can
tell us what to do but it's like it
feels like a
psychological need and that's me trying
to understand it cuz I'm like there's no
other unless it is some like doth
protest thing but there's no other
explanation again I'm not trying to
defend him I'm
saying we can have that discussion yeah
I mean it is interesting because it's
like I I still don't like it yeah but I
also don't want to shut anyone out of my
heart I don't want to be like well he's
a [__] no no no no no I mean I get it
it just and I feel like everyone can be
a fan of somebody and I you know I I can
admire Chappelle in my own ways but it's
like I'm just you know or the the other
big guys you know who I feel were all
kind of like nerds in high school
themselves at one point that's what's so
strange and now they're like these like
Alpha like Titan
they become the thing that bullied them
into becoming the thing it's so
fascinating they got bullied and othered
so hard and felt so unsafe that they
built an Iron Man suit and became as
strong and as shiny as they could be
yeah and then they and can fly over
masturbating and everyone's going to be
like exactly exactly it to us yes and
but then you use that strength to go
back and like Bully the people the lower
the lower people
yeah so I just I know that in my head
and I just never want to be that you
know it's honestly I mean we're talking
about power yeah we're talking when you
talk about kind of like losing touch or
whatever it's like power corrupts and
there's no exception to that
meaning what else would happen I guess
but but I do stay up at night thinking
about like what you could what you could
do one thing would be not to talk about
it
imagine I would never talk about
something that I was never like did not
have any knowledge about right you know
what I mean so it's just weird when I
hear anybody talk about like I would not
go up on stage and be like Jews am I
right I'm not Jewish right right I I I
don't you know I I know Hanukkah I know
the holidays I the Hat I know my friends
I am not one to yeah to engage with like
you know what it is you ever get
sometimes I'll get in a cab mhm this
this happens and sometimes because I'm
white which is [__] up they'll just
assume I'm down for a racist joke God
really yeah that used to happen in New
York some guy would be like this
neighbor used to be different I'll tell
you and you're like oh here we go but
even worse and what these kinds of jokes
remind me of whether it's Chappelle or
anybody is the kind of jokes that people
tell you after a show when they realiz
they know you're a comedian and they're
like I got one for you oh yes someone
imitated someone with a physical
disability walking I would be like oh
yikes yikes like that would be like I
like I I'm a people pleasy person but
you'd be like I that's that that's not
for me you know what I mean please stop
but like it's weird when that's to use
all of that influence and power to kind
of you do it as like
jokes people tell you after the show
kind yeah yeah yeah does that do you
relate to that oh oh absolutely I
remember one of um I remember being in
Las Vegas with a friend of
mine and we still joke about it now just
cuz the situation it was just so we
wanted to go to like a really shitty
Diner like one of those
gross like Vegas Off the Strip diners
with just brick ack and not a Cracker
Barrel but but something below like Five
Below a Cracker Barrel wow Five Below a
Cracker Barrel and this was like right
when um Raider Stadium all that stuff
kind of just opened up and so we're like
wow Vegas has really changed it's all
expensive and shiny and our waitress
came over to us and she had blue
eyeshadow garage
doors blush lip teeth like yeah like the
whole thing and I was like oh my God
she's everything I need to know
everything about her and she came up to
us and she's like what are y'all doing
in Vegas and we're like oh we're just
you know
visiting my friend looks at her she's
like yeah when did it's like changed a
lot of it's like different now you know
she goes I'll tell you what happened to
Vegas and we're like oh
God you have given me the best example I
feel so seen I'll tell you what happened
I'll tell you what happened in Vegas
like Tim Burton film peewee's big
adventure like the light goes off behind
her harsh I'll tell you what happened
harsh Spotlight on her Raider
Stadium that's all we needed we're like
oh got it wow cuz all the weed all the
you know she's like I'll tell you what
happened to Vegas Raiders stadium and
I'm like wow tell me you're racist
without telling me you're a racist I was
like can we get more um juice did you
say juice juice
juice juice you wanton juice no juice
please God give us juice you got to say
the orange there God I
mean hey I got a good one for you that
always ends with like oh no please don't
I know I know and that's how I feel when
I watch jokes like that and I'm why are
we doing what we what they think we're
doing which is not what we're doing yeah
yeah
this episode is brought to you by better
help getting to know yourself can be a
lifelong process especially because
we're always growing and changing like
before I went to therapy I had no idea I
was codependent or how to end a
relationship in a healthy and productive
way or set up boundaries with family and
people that I work with but that's what
therapy is all about deepening your
self-awareness and your self-
understanding and your understanding of
others to be honest because sometimes we
don't know what we want or why we react
the way we do until we talk through
things I've always said talk therapy is
greater than the sum of its parts and
it's changed my life better help
connects you with a licensed therapist
who can take you on that journey of
self-discovery from wherever you are
because the more you know about yourself
the more easily you can maneuver through
life with less suffering and more
clarity relationships grief loss anxiety
you name it talking about it with a
professional helps so if you're thinking
about starting therapy give better help
a try it's entirely online designed to
be convenient flexible and suited to
your schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire and get matched with a
licensed therapist you can even switch
therapists at any time for no additional
charge discover your potential with
betterhelp visit betterhelp.com weirdo
toay to get 10% off your first month
that's better HP betterhelp.com
weirdo back to
Justin what are um I love that that's
very interesting what are your obsess
tell me some of your obsess what are the
what are the things what are your like
don't get me started things like if if I
bring up a topic and the
more boring or specific the better but
there are a couple things that people
I'll I'll give you some of mine if it D
what are yours cold exposure therapy
like what oh like dunk tanks don't ask
about
it okay no I'm just kidding I hatte it
that you you yeah plunging that stuff
but that's the thing that if I'm at a
party and Val's next to me and someone
brings it up she looks at me like oh God
here we go not not even oh God but she's
just like you just stepped in it how do
I step in it with you what's the thing
that you just can't get enough of if
someone's into it you're into them oh if
if someone's
into something that I'm into like but
the thing that you're like oh instant
wait you like cold plunges if you liked
cold plunging I would be like I can't
wait to talk about I'm going to have to
come over and do it I'm fascinated with
it I've never done one yeah but I'll do
one I thought you were like I've had it
that's my meth okay mine is
probably what is if someone is
into ancient
aliens uh hot
mustard uh tight socks uh pajamas um
Dolly Parton perfect
strangers um uh karate Judo near-death
experiences um horror movies I think
that one is one which one horror films
oh and Dolly Parton socks yeah um no I
think um I think horror films is a good
one you love a good scare I do yeah yeah
yeah and I love
like I don't know I like witchy stuff
really yeah I like I like um ever been
to Salem no I want to it's on the list
you'd like it yeah like witchy stuff I
like I like you know you mean like
wiccans like real witches or yeah I just
feel like I just like that process of
old mysticism earthy you know Pagan I
say Pagan you know Pagan just means uh
people that live in the town like people
that don't live in the city that's you
know what else is Pagan Santa Claus you
know what else is pag like it's all
Pagan is the most Pagan no Pagan is just
ordinary it it means not from the church
like you know what the shortest day of
the year is yeah December 21st why cuz
of the solstice you know why Pagan yeah
that's right it's all Pagan so I'm just
like fascinated with like old mysticism
and herbs and I was thinking about this
recently manifesting and stuff like that
yeah okay Vision border I'm not a vision
board but I am like a Deja Vu yes kind
of a guy or like or like
um noticing little things like oh
interesting just saw this I was just
thinking about yeah that kind of stuff I
was thinking about the Chappelle Shas
special Chappelle the Shas special the
shal on the way down and then the next
car in front of me had a sticker that
said
closer it wasn't a Chappelle sticker but
that was his last special was the closer
I was like count it I was like that's
weird and those things happen I love
little moments like that they one my
Winks little Cosmic winks and they
happen so much and so often that I've
stopped keeping track of them have you
ever gone to a psychic that blew your
mind oh yeah yeah yeah it's weird
because I had a um I have two friends
named patrique and Paul and they um Paul
Paul Paul P um but he does um like
coffee ground readings oh like ancient
Armenian fun I think it's Armenian oh
God okay I'm going to count that as a
synchronicity cuz every morning I make
an espresso like Turkish coffee and
every morning I look at it and it's like
that and I look for a face or just for
fun yeah and sometimes it's funny you
are are we ever seeing anything other
than our own projections that's a big
question but like I I see something I'm
like that looks like something I was
just thinking about it's fun yeah and it
was weird cuz he he was like he's like I
see a key here and I'm like what and
he's like you need to hang a key on your
tree and I'm like what are you talking
about and he's like cuz that's going to
open up so many doors for you in 2024
just hang this key on a tree and I'm
like so I go
home couple days go
by we're getting out the Christmas
decorations everything and I open a like
a box and I have a key
ornament that you didn't know you had I
was like oh yeah I have this key
ornament let's put it on the
tree and I was like what that's a fancy
took a picture of it I was like I have a
key on a tree is like I have no idea
where that came from but yeah key on a
tree key on a tree and I was like oh
yeah and I had it up there all all
December and so hopefully it'll and then
you booked this
open yeah and then you were cancelled
and then I was talking [__] about
shabelle gender bendy God oh yeah that
was I'll never forget that alarm I
remember people called Kurt Cobain
gender bendy and that's that's when I
thought that was okay no gender bending
was like
was like Boy George yeah I know but Kurt
used to wear a Kurt like oh yeah he did
wear dress yeah he did do that and that
was a thing in the '90s I had friends
that wore dresses in in the same sort of
Alti oh now everyone is yeah no well
going back to our jealousy Theory I'm
jealous I wish I was um Shalom yeah like
this post sexuality I wish I was they
them right I would love to be a they
them just kind of cruising around just
whatever on a hoverboard I can't do it
now you can't do it now like if you
showed up at the comedy store I'm died
in the wool in full
gown it's
over yeah I will support you yeah I will
be like right there it is yeah there it
is and that's not your pronoun it it's
just it's there he is or there there
they are I don't know there they are
like Eddie isard yeah yeah but he's but
Eddie's been doing it forever yeah what
I mean I I don't I feel like the window
might have closed yeah like I went to um
a Christmas party obviously this past
Christmas and I was looking around I'm
like I'm a dork you're a square no dude
being gay in the '90s was like
what and now it's a
snooze it's a [__] snooze and I
forget who I was talking but like a lot
of the now gays the young gays don't
even know that it was and I'm happy Oh
Billy ish Billy ish Billy ish was like I
I just thought everyone knew and I'm
like wait is Billy eish a lesbian yeah
oh I didn't know she's like I I guess I
I guess I came out I don't and I'm like
you [__] I'm like he was a non thing
just just like a I mean yeah whoops a
doodle yeah meanwhile I'm taking a
redheaded Mormon girl to prom
and dressed like the Titanic and like we
had themes and you know all highlighted
my hair no Billy ish I didn't know she
was uh gay but like that's a great
example of a level of Freedom built on
the backs of a lot of uh discomfort and
then where does it go from there I mean
it'll just be I just feel like nobody
gives this [__] anymore so I think that
and what what that is now will be
considered giving a [__] like later
it'll be like even more liberated is
what I'm saying it's like there'll
always be a way to to lighten it here's
something that infuriates me okay
bathrooms I hate it I hate bathro Oh you
mean gender assigned bathroom just just
go just make every just make every
toilet individual like God intended I
don't want to share I don't want to hear
someone's dump next to me H there's I I
refuse to poop in public refuse is there
anything better we did a monologue on my
old talk show about the perfect bathroom
and it's it's a one-seater yeah it's got
a bolt I want to see that it's locked
not a Twist you know when it's the Twist
on the knob no I just did this in uh in
Arizona I had to take a poop in the wild
I'm Clos the Wild what do you mean the
wild no I mean in a public bathroom but
it was a one-seater and I was like this
is great and then it was one of those
twists on the knob and then I'm like I
don't I don't trust it so I I lock it
but then I pull it opens I lock it I try
it on the side it's locked but it
doesn't it's not latching so you just
taking one of those [__] coyote shits
where you're like any minute and I'm
like please not during the wipe I'll
take them seeing me pantsless looking at
my phone but not when I'm getting up in
there looking at it I got where was it
where was it what was the location
coffee shop oh yeah which means was
there a code there was no code Tempe it
was rough no I'm with you can you unpack
this with me so I go home to Boston
yeah again you don't nobody's needing
you to fix this just want your hot take
sure sure sure and I I went to coffee
with my dad which was really sweet I I
was glad I had that idea I know tell me
I'm still thinking of coyote
and wild just any moment you might be
Adam Ray I always think of Adam Ray cuz
he had that one joke where that does
happen where there's no lock on the
bathroom and you could be the most you
know don't care but the minute someone
walks in on you you're just like
please I walked into my father-in-law I
I still think about it it makes me laugh
every time it's not right it's our
special place yeah is this is one of
those deadbolt things it's not even I
want to hear a I Want A Lash and then I
want to you it's a double lock you lock
the door and then you lock lock the
latch goes up in its little house yeah I
want a zombie proof I want I I don't
want a just a little like metal thing
popping out and you just go no give me
Justin give
yeah while we're here hold
me uh don't knock the door is locked you
know what's happening you know what's
happening do you really need me to pinch
it mid because you have to yeah and
certainly don't try the door twice I'm
gauging everything God there's nothing
worse than a public bathroom in fact a
good public poop uh policy for me if I
have to do one in an airport is is
earbuds cuz I'm with you the whole
[__] thing is disgusting sick I don't
the sink is wet the floor is airport I
have to put my bag down in this this
strangers urine yep you know who doesn't
know how to his own penis you
celebrating God God did was it New
Year's God just the Splash and spittle
okay we're going to figure this out so I
go to coffee with my dad CU I was like I
I'm always trying to think of things to
do and I was like let's just do what he
does hot tip if anybody's trying to
connect with their dad just ask if you
can join him when he's doing the thing
he was going to do anyway just go to
coffee I was like I'll come to Coffee of
course it's 5:30 in the morning he's I
opened my eyes he's by the bed dark room
I just opened my eyes it didn't even
scare me that's how boundaryless my
parents house is I open my eyes and I
wasn't and when I did your podcast I
told you I'm like a Victorian ninnie
like I startled easily totally not when
it's my dad I open my eyes there he is
in his work cloth and I must have smell
I'm not making was he crouched down like
just staring at you or was it just like
like oh oh okay okay and then he left
and I go Dad he was like cuz I set an
alarm he said I leave at 6 uh so I sat
in alarm for 5:45 but 5:30 is just by
the bed like the 6 cents okay yeah no no
no we go to coffee but I got a real and
there's no way to say this without
sounding a little bit elitist Coastal
elitist so I'm just going to own it I'm
a [__] Coastal Elite In This Moment
[__] I'm saying your truth I'm living
my truth yeah so I got a taste Coastal
Elite alert of what kind of like a
normal Boston morning Boston coffee shop
and what the conversations were was it a
Dunkin Donuts I said coffee shop oh you
know it was that's my Coastal LST yeah
going was it Dunkin Donuts it was that's
kind of your down the nose was it pink
and purple and orange yes it was yeah so
we're at Duncan and we actually had a
nice time and then a couple people
coming and I was really touched that
everybody was so happy to see my dad I
was like oh he's like that's like a
figure and all different ages and and
shapes and sizes and everything and I
was like this is great I love my dad and
we're having this coffee and at one
point this woman comes in and just
immediately jumps into a little bit of a
transphobic thing in the morning right
away God and I think in not in her
defense but I think she's like oh it's
his son that's the comedian he'll like
this oh no so they're talking about how
her office now
has a a a a trans woman that goes in the
woman's room uhhuh and and she again I
think she's trying to be funny but she's
like and everybody's freaked out you go
in there and there's a guy you know so
I'm like like I'm not even pretend
laughing I'm I'm given zero I'm like
have you got have you do you have your
coffee in front of you yet are you
waiting for it I'm drinking it so I'm
there for all of this God I imag yeah
here's what I want to unpack though cuz
I've been thinking a lot about
it you you don't want a transgender
woman in the woman's room and I was like
really just walk through this with me
the issue
is because they're they're attracted to
you because I go there are already
lesbians going in women's room isn't
that just kind of like like let's let's
have the conversation no absolutely it
because someone is potentially sexually
attracted to you and the and I go like
your diarrhea is so irresistible I have
irresistible diarrhea that's why I don't
go to public bathrooms cuz it is like I
just don't want to ruin everybody's life
with a new pedestal yeah you'll never
hear diarrhea like this everyone's
getting involuntary ere sorry everybody
oh keep talking I'm almost there I just
changed your keep ass talking keep that
ass
talking so is that the concern that your
diarrhea I that a transwoman is going to
be sexually aroused but a lesbian would
also be sexually roused and and that is
not an issue like that's not so then is
it because it's a uh Stronger woman is
that like really like I don't know let's
unpack it cuz I feel like there's gay
guys that go into bathrooms as well and
that's what I'm saying you know the most
disgusting place in the world if we're
all standing up against a urinal and
someone's looking over at your dick it's
like there it is yeah yeah go for it or
if you go to a concert then there's like
drunk girls in the men's bathroom
because they want to go into the men's
bathroom because there's a line a line
yes so they're like I just want to pee
real quick and guys are like get out of
hell you females like well that's
interesting because they're not right
yeah the times that I've been in a men's
room and women come in but then again
see this is something Val like we we I'm
not saying it's always true we're
considered and often statistically are
larger so they're not a threat to us
physically so they're like a visitor so
then it's almost like who cares Welcome
to our weird world you know what I mean
although I could see a guy like us not
wanting to take a dump next to a lady
but that's kind of silly that seems
conditioning I'm grossed out by everyone
that's what I'm saying that's what I
think we should be grossed out by
everyone I don't think it's I I think
it's just
weird and it makes you an [__] to be
like so this this transom is At This
Woman's office right yeah so are you
saying that she's not feminine enough
for you right and well that's what
transparent really covered because
there's that transwoman that is so
passing that that would be okay yeah but
it's also like if you have like a trans
man yeah and I feel like trans men
they're taking the testosterone they've
got facial hair you know they're they're
more passing is that it yeah so it's
like if they walk into a men's
bathroom I just think it's like if a guy
looks at another guy and is
like wait a minute right you know I just
I'm not looking at anyone that but it's
also if I was a woman in a in a female
in a in a woman's
bathroom and I if there was a transman
who's legally a woman coming into that
bathroom that's when I'd be like wait a
minute no no no no what are you doing I
see the point you're making right so in
comes a in comes the government and the
law right and I was going to say in
comes a very male presenting but female
born a woman assigned female comes in
and now with that is that what you want
see that's okay see now we're cooking
that's what I'm saying [__] let people
want the trans woman to go in the men's
room but that means the trans man is
going to come in the room so I think
this is looking us right in the face it
absolutely in the future stupid it's all
one seeders all one seeders which is My
Paradise yeah I've never liked the
ballpark trough I was I can't do I was
just going a say trough I'm I'm a
deeply confident person couldn't for a
million dollars pee at the trough an
iced trough an ice truff and I see
dozens you can't not see the ding-dongs
oh and that's fine but I'm like how is
this a comfortable place for me cuz I
get in my head I'm like they're all
peeing I'm not peeing they know I'm not
peeing I'm that guy oh then there's the
guy okay and then there's the
um the corner guy at the trough Corner
trough Corner trough that's where you go
to the very end of the trough
and you
turn so you're at the corner I like this
guy that might be me now
yeah don't look I don't you know I think
here's
insation the bathroom is disgusting
bathrooms are gross everything's gross
now it's a
forgotten it's like The Untouchables M
it's like don't look at us don't think
about it just look uh and when I go into
like a nice hotel bathroom and they have
like seven doors that shut with the
French yeah Venetian
wood Venetian wood Venetian wood it's a
vene come down and a turn and click
luxury and a [__] it goes down and
you can tell they're cleaning it and
there's even a little accent in there
maybe a little jar with sticks of
vanilla God or a poopery if you're lucky
a thing of poopery just or just
something that you just I have I have a
question for you yeah you go in a public
bathroom let's say where are we doesn't
matter you're in an office M you go on a
one seater you take a dump there's a
thing of Glade MH this is a this is an
insight into your
psyche you've just taken a [__] so
you're not clean you are now unclean and
there's the Glade and there's the sink
do you Glade and then wash your hands or
wash your hands and then
Glade because that
Glade you're really relying on your
brothers and sisters yeah are they
dumping and then glading and then
washing or are we trusting our brothers
and sisters they wouldn't touch the
Glade with their [__] hands oh I see
what you're saying you see what I mean
are you re [__] Your Hands by
touching that Glade or do you trust
first of all respect I don't even [__]
in public
facts you already said that I don't but
you just had to okay I just had to you
had
to um I'm going to tell you I'm a Glade
and then wash I'm not even ashamed Glade
wash I didn't even think about that you
got to Glade then wash I don't know what
that cans I don't know if it I didn't
even think of the germs on the can I
don't when I squirt a lemon into my
drink I'm not soaking that lemon in
there you ever see a bartender drop a
lemon on the ground you think he washes
it off you're putting the ground in your
drink you just put the ground put the
ground in my drink everything that's on
the ground in my drink in the drink you
might as well just get that like that uh
where they set the drinks on like in the
well yeah empty that out pour it in pour
it in a glass and drink it drink that if
you're going to be filthy this is how
the plague started limes and lemons
limes and lemons on a bar floor no
magusta if I dropped a lemon I wouldn't
wash it off you just chop it up put it
in the drink so they I go I want a
pelino lemon or lime do I look like I
want to die yeah
no okay so never poop in public
never never no it just scares me too
much everything we've already covered
unless it is like a single Venetian door
we're talking like a four season but I
mean I even felt like um there was one
time where I was like at the airport and
I was like oh God it's happening it's
happening and I went and there was a um
what is it a family family bathroom love
a family bathroom and I was just like
there was a lock on there I was like
occupied not only is there a lock it
turns red and says OCC oh absolutely I
stared at the changing table I think
this is a modern that buddy if I was a
congressman trying to say we need a
nationwide s only only genderless
one-seater bathrooms I would say my
brothers and sisters you know I am right
watch the trend in the80s the family
bathroom was never taken by anybody but
a family and now it is always occupied
because everyone wants a gender private
bathroom there's no why does it stop
before the floor who designed this that
[__] guy with the motel that he
crawled in the vents and watched people
doing it did you watch that he made
[__] the bathroom system God what a
nightmare like it's h that guy looked
like he did that too the the in the in
the vents and like watched do this there
was a doc there there was a motel the
motel and he built and my favorite part
is or it's weird to say favorite
favorite part the most striking part was
that his wife knew he was a look Lop oh
yeah and like supported his dream of
having a motel that he designed like
Norman bat style totally with vents that
he could crawl up in and just watch
people doing it God that was oh God no I
know but I feel
like back to the bathroom B to the B
what was I going to say it was something
along the lines oh you went into the
family bathroom yeah and you made you
should have individual stalls because
there's nothing more gross
than the
public agreed I don't want to
hear you know okay look we're going to
move on from this topic just to yes and
you okay I'm thinking of the audience so
everybody worried that we're going to
talk about this we're almost done
farting at urinals there should be a
fine I don't need it just cuz you're in
the gross room doesn't mean you can do
everything gross I don't know you I know
your name we're so close it's like we're
in line at a yogurt shop yeah why is
that happening yeah why is no one just
fart maybe they are I think they are I
think people are trash I honestly like
people are letting them rip on airplanes
I was just going to say the barefoot guy
like flipping the movie thing with his
toes I've seen that I've seen the guy
pushing the screen it a socked foot but
still get the [__] out of here like
putting your foot on the on the like in
front of you like people don't know
biting your toenails my mom would shave
her calluses in my car she'd take her
shoes off and
just I'm like this is before I knew how
to use my big boy voice so I just allow
it to happen it looks like a [__]
snow globe back
there what is this like Olive Garden
parmesan like what is this just tell me
when to stop
keep going mom tell me when to
stop it's just a plate of cheese now Mom
just tell me when you just made it a bit
yeah thank you very much sick you ever
see a ghost yeah knew it tell me tell me
have you cuz you're the most fun to see
a ghost I would love to have seen you
see a ghost I mean I've seen I saw one
when I was a kid what was that that was
like
um so I was probably like
in second grade and I was asleep and I
remember waking up and my hallway was
like all lit up like my my bedroom door
was
open and the hallway lit up like a blue
light and I remember this woman and I
had my eyes closed cuz I I think I had
like lost a
tooth so I was waiting for the Tooth
Fairy to come okay so if you write this
in your book the first line of the story
is I think think I had lost a tooth I
think I lost a tooth yeah the lights in
the hallway were off lit up but like not
on not like it was it wasn't electricity
it just it was like a blue light and
this woman came in and she was wearing a
pink dress came into your room yeah and
it sounds weird because it is Tooth
Fairy adjacent which could be the
chapter title Tooth Fairy adjacent cuz
it sounds like oh you were just like you
saw the tooth fairy and I'm like no
no but my eyes were closed like this cuz
I didn't want to get in trouble I didn't
want the Tooth Fairy to see me so this
woman comes over towards the front of my
bed and I remember being scared and I
closed my eyes really really tight and
then I gave it some time and I opened my
eyes and she was gone and it was dark
again in my bedroom and then the second
one
was that guy whoa whoa whoa and I
remember that like to this day no I I
believe it I'm just going to ask uh at
least one followup is there a chance
that your delightful mom wanted to give
you the thrill of your life
no no my mom wasn't dressing up like the
[__] Tooth Fairy light I mean that's
that's a lot that's dedication and we're
how were you asleep or you were almost
asleep I was asleep and I remember
waking up and and I woke up and that's
when the light like slowly came on
really full bright blue yeah and then
the second one was at the comedy store
so that was pretty cool too well let's
not talk about that at all have you yeah
no I do oh yeah I want to I haven't ever
seen it The Comedy Store is haunted oh
yeah did you not know that you mean with
Bad Comics well honey depending on the
night depending on the night I'm just
kidding everybody I love the story I
just oh yeah I mean RI and bits just
riff and bits so much who's the mob and
all that stuff was affiliated with the
store I remember being at the store and
and mosha took me the first time I was
there was like there's a staircase and
you turn around and there's a little
window like the hole where the gun went
the hole where the gun the gun window so
they were like they would walk people up
here to whack them and it is a perfect
place to whack somebody and then they'd
open the door and push him out of the
door cuz the door led to like the
parking lot so that's real so yeah
they'd be like oh walk up here and
they'd be like all right let's go and
they'd open the door and then they'd
shove them out and like break their legs
and like kill them oh no so why was the
mob in The Comedy Store before it was
the comedy St successful or it was the
it was seros yeah it was the restaurant
but it was also a comedy club no The
Comedy Club came at like that the late
like
7374 it was a mob restaurant yeah okay
so tell me who you
saw so apparently I saw Gus who was a
bouncer uh at zeros I I go there several
times a month you don't ever get a weird
vibe from that place well yeah I just
assumed it was standup comedy well I
mean it's just it's it's heavy the air
is heavy I know what you mean yeah like
you walk in and you're
like it's a weird funky but I I've
leaned into it being like it's like a
fun house see yeah it's like kind of
like and that's what mosha told me he
was like you got to like embrace the
Black Walls and the little Coke piano
and plastic chairs I looked up at the
ceiling recently it was like a dream it
looks like alien it looks like Ridley
Scott's alien it's like the ceilings are
Co in like black garbage
bag in the Green Room of the main room
of the main room look up next time I
will I don't think I've looked the walls
don't meet like that they're like it
looks like the alien is there oh I'll
look at that no yeah but like I remember
leaving I was in The Green Room of the
main room and it was like late at night
saw no it wasn't like there but I I was
leaving the stage it was this was like
200 11 12 13 Maybe
okay it was late at night I used to hang
out all night
like those were some times but anyways
I'm leaving and I'm walking off the
stage going towards that doorway that
goes into the main room from the hallway
uhhuh okay so I'm walking out that way
and I look over and there's a guy wait
the the the hallway with the pictures
yeah so that entrance into the main room
you know what I'm talking about yeah the
belly room's to your right the kitchen's
to your right walking down towards the
main so if you're walking out of yeah
yeah yeah so yes the original rooms to
your left you're walking toward down the
hallway belly rooms up the stairs then
you go into the main room so leaving
from The Green Room down the stage out
into that hallway right so I'm walking
and I look over and there's this guy
there's nobody here the club's like
pretty much closed for the night it's
like 2:00 in the morning and um I look
over and there's just this man sitting
in one of the chairs by the door and I
look over and he has a gray bowler hat
on and he has a gray trench coat on and
he has no face like it was just black
stop your I'm telling you stop and it's
like and and like and like a smoke a
light smoke is coming from you shut up I
swear there's a light Dick Tracy villain
smoke coming up from it all gray with no
face and I look over and I go nope and I
ran down the hallway and Jeff Scott the
piano player was there at the time and I
was like I think I saw ghost I think I
saw a ghost and he's like well what did
he look like and I'm like he was I told
him and he was like oh yeah that's Gus
he was the security guard here at SOS
and I'm like without a beat and I was
like oh oh of course it was yeah did you
go back to that spot send the guy that's
not scared I know I I it was definitely
like let see if [__] no face is here
like if maybe maybe it was just a
regular no face no there was nobody
there I can't it was cool
and he didn't look translucent he just
looked like a
person what do you mean by translucent
could you see through
him translucent Chappelle has all these
new translucent jokes like why won't he
leave the ghost Community alone leave
them alone haven't they done enough yes
um no it wasn't transl well I don't know
it was it I see what you're saying it
wasn't like I could see through him but
it was just very
faint yeah in in the dark
mhm yeah buy a chair just work in
security have you seen the Unsolved
Mysteries about The Comedy Store the old
episode shut the [__] up to me there's
an Unsolved Mysteries UNS Mysteries W
stack goes to the comedy store it's on
YouTube and some of that is just kind of
like really CU it'll be like you know I
worked at the store from like 19 70
something to 70 whatever and then I you
know I put we had tablecloths and
ashtray that we used to put on the
tables and then we turn her back and we
turn around and they were all folded
again with the asay Stacked and the
chairs stacked and I'm like really like
it's hard to know when the cameras show
up I know I know once Robert Stack is
there you're like maybe it wasn't just
an an astray fell as they were stacked
they were Robert
stacked it's like being on Cops even the
crazy people act a little crazier and
the cops act more like cops obviously
cuz the cameras are cameras
Florida that's a great one oh yeah it
helped us know Florida yeah really does
cops is so Florida when I when I watch
it it gets
humid that just be sweating okay
anything on the meaning of life that
we're we're almost done uh meaning you
can you can spend all your energy here
and then we're just going to go back
into this amorphous in between feeling
of the first week of January h on the
meaning of life well you were raised
relig yeah anything carry over do you
have any worldview including atheism
that would be a
worldview do you think well we just
talked about seeing a ghost so your
grandparents past do you feel them do
you have any relationship to them do you
think they're just zeros or completely
gone no I mean I'm I'm I'm definitely a
spiritual person and I hate when people
say that because I just feel like it's
very vague I have to say that too I go
just spiritual I mean I get I feel like
there is and all this other stuff I just
I hate when people weaponize religion
sure um I'm just kidding I mean it's
it's the worst it's the worst yeah it's
the worst I don't understand how one
religion is better than the other and we
can attack this other group for being
different or whatever it's just it's so
it's exhausting yeah and I just hate I
hate uh charlatans yeah who could call
themselves religious and are not yeah uh
but what how does it take its shape are
you have you had religious
experiences it's just a
feeling how do you pursue this feeling
what what does it mean when you say
you're spiritual I mean I just feel like
there's kind of like along you know
along the lines of like a a Deja Vu I
feel like we're all kind of here for a
reason I definitely
believe when somebody is gone that
doesn't necessarily mean they're gone
you know smoke face next like a smoke
face nightclub bouncer or you know even
just thinking about something and
looking over and just seeing like a
hummingbird or something you're just
like oh that's nice like seeing little
things around like I I just feel like
everything has a purpose if we all just
kind of step away from
our gross public toilet selves yes and
our self-seeking just like all I've been
getting a I so I'm at that coffee shop
in Tempe where where I took it down and
you ever been in a bright it's a bright
day you go in a shop and there's people
on the outside and they can't see in the
shop cuz the sun's too bright and they
put their their dumb
faces and you're you can see them but
they can't see you and they're like
what's in here and I was like why is
that so annoying and I was like cuz
that's what we're all doing yeah no
matter who you are no matter what you're
doing to some extent you're just going
is there anything in there for me mhm
can I eat something or [__] something is
there something comfortable exciting
interesting something for me and if you
can put away something for me and look
at I guess you could say look at the big
picture that that can be very not that
not just can be that is very peace
inducing just like getting over yourself
little oh I wish we could get over
ourselves trying did you see the video
of France uh uh for New Year's it's kind
of going around right now um everyone's
outside of the Shan zis the you know the
big statue and Paris and everyone
everyone everyone is on their phone
everyone is on their phone they're doing
the countdown and it's just blue screens
all the way to the front of the the Sha
Al it's just like no one is there no one
is there no one's present no one no
one's kissing no one's like we did it
everyone it's just blue screens wow
counting it's insane I wish it Larry
David was there so we could just zoom
in
yeah Jeff Jeff Garland is like go to New
Year's you can kiss a stranger you'll
kiss somebody go to the Chalice he's
like you think I go to kid say you kiss
on New Year it doesn't mean anything no
one gave it's a new year that second
isn't this year it's not last year it's
a no second it's a Timeless second no
it's Jerry God it's so good but he goes
and everyone's on their phone yeah
everyone's on their
phone that's how I feel that's going to
become Our Lives that's our cross if if
that sound can go with anything what
does that say about
us oh my God he was so right that that
sound is Modern Life someone falling
someone like getting
robbed it's so good
I
wonder when we're dying if we'll be
like the credits roll and you're like no
no no
no the funniest death that would be a
great thing if we heard that and when
you hear that sound that means the
episode's over you're on your way
out you're just having a good day
executive producer Larry David why is is
that in front of me oh I'm dying oh
that's what it is wait we're at a
restaurant
yeah and Jeff gr com he's joking he h
does no one know the he
lick God that would be great I could see
them doing a curb on the heick maneuver
heick he's a guy final season they name
him after his whole Legacy is how to say
people when they're joking you know how
he died he choked
well what a delight the final question
for you jart is oh that's what my
friends call me I knew it jart I knew it
good friends call me that when I was
driving down I was like I bet jart is
like Yeah The Long friends it's the long
friend those my long friends call me
that well you're a friendly so you're J
absolutely thank you for doing this the
last one is yes can you tell me a time
in your life when you laughed really
really really really really really hard
here's the take the pressure off it
doesn't have to be a good story just how
old are you where are you maybe what
happened here are the prompts did
someone fall did someone fart were you
in church were you at a wedding a eulogy
some situation where you're not supposed
to laugh were you at a tour of a library
was it the first day of school did your
friend put a Cheeto up his nose did you
fall did you fart did like just God
tears going down your face and to make
it even easier it can just be recently
like something that your partner did
something that happened over the
holidays something your weird dog that
we never got to did oh well I mean it is
recently recently was uh over the
weekend we were laughing so hard because
um we do have this dog we got we finally
got to it we got to the dog um and I'm a
little on edge because this is the first
time that both of us have been gone so
we're like oh God is she barking at
everything is she like you know what I
mean but we've got that thing that just
shits out like puppy treats yeah so and
it's a camera and I feel like an [__]
cuz I'm like now I'm that person
treat but what a gift yeah it's real fun
but anyways um what kind of dog it is a
King Charles cavalier and she is just
the sweetest little yeah I'll show you
yeah go ahead she's she's my screen
saver now need I mean just that's
beautiful the sweetest little thing
that's her right there yeah and you're a
group text from Evan cob that's my
boyfriend yeah okay sorry is that public
info and Evan Cobb he's like okay oh no
but we went over to our friend Christa's
house for uh New Year's and she has a
King Charles and it's 11 it's like a
little older guy and she has this other
dog named Luna who is just this like
Terrier Terror just just you know what I
mean it's just very like
uh what's the word just not controlling
it's um like this is her space
domineering domineering yeah very
dominant the other one's just like you
know real sweet and then my dog is just
one-year-old and just like a new puppy
and so real sweet and we were laughing
because of King Charles's like you know
royalty so it's like this we we kept
like a Victoria nin very much our yes
yes just oh gracious cuz the other dogs
yipping and yapping at everything and
our dog's just like you didn't say you
know we were calling Luna the other dog
French like she was just very like
de like just very like aggressive and
yelling and our dog is just like please
don't bother me right now perfect but
the other dog was just staring at our
dog just the whole time and we were just
laughing so hard cuzz we were like we
just stopped calling the other dog Luna
we were calling it we were like look at
France France is over there just like
perfect just scouring and we were
laughing so hard so that was a uh that
was the last time you're going have so
many dogs are great for Laughs God just
that they they are like your little kids
yeah you know what I mean and I never
thought that I was like like I I was
text I called my boyfriend all the way
over here and I was just like oh God we
left her he's like it feels weird right
I'm like yeah it feels like oh I feel
awful yeah and I'm like wow I'm that guy
now to be like well I left my child at
home unattended you're reminding me of
when I first got Brody we were crossing
uh this Vermont just over there and I
didn't know much about dog ownership but
he was a real nervous he's a rescue so
whatever We rescued him from was still
sort of bothering him I took him on a
real nervous walk and he used to [__]
like 13 times per walk and I was like
God damn how many bags do you need yeah
and then I'm like walking come home he's
walking weird I think it's cuz he's
nervous he's already [__] about 12 times
I'm like Let's cross the street come on
let's go he's being real skittish but
I'm being sweet walking with him and
every time I cross fromont I think about
this he just took like seven or eight
logs on the crosswalk yeah like a coyote
in the wild like a coyote in the wild he
doesn't have our problem he's like if
it's here it's here could you imagine
and then cars drove by just activating
every log just running it flat releasing
every every feature that they have wait
wait the cars were running over did you
run out of bags because he was I
couldn't pick them up cuz there were so
many because the light was changing and
and so he's just leaving a trail of
breadcrumbs like he wants us to find our
way back yes yes yes and then I get over
and I just stand I get the bag but TR
it's too late traffic is now coming and
it's like [__] New
Year poppers yeah and it was hum
and that's the kind of fun you have in
store yeah I know I can't wait I know
I'm thinking about it I'm like am I
going to be in trouble when I get home
is are my shoes going to be ripped up
cuz there's been no accidents in the
house not that gentlemen not that
gentlemen watch out for the Christmas
tree too cuz they'll pee on that they
why wouldn't they I know that's on us I
know we brought their toilet inside on
Christmas a new dog is like thank you
yeah finally it's the she's the sweetest
dog so I I love her to death but it is
like oh now holidays are over yeah the
holiday is over now it's just your dog
now it's my dog you're going to love it
yeah it's going to be great be fun thank
you well thank you Justin marale will
you email me a clip of your standup that
we can play up top just to kind of intro
yeah you yeah it can be anything it can
be anything okay it doesn't have to be
new or just something that's on YouTube
that's short okay get it to me and give
it to Katie absolutely and thank you so
much when you say keep it crispy it's
how we end where it says it right there
oh I thought I was looking into a camera
that's your line keep it crispy there it
is wait I want to look into it keep it
crispy happy New Year he picked the two
shot thanks budy thank
you oh yeah you made it win you made it
win you made it win oh yeah you made it
wi you made ITN you made it wi oh yeah
you made it you made it you made it oh
yeah